morning it's the day of the Oscars and
Francesca's here we're getting ready
prepared to get ready for the big day
I've got all my note cards of fashion
things that I need thanks to the ink
I made these last night like the rafting
oh yeah just like this granny chic but
if you watch the getting ready video
you've already seen all this so yeah
public send me like a bunch of Joel
rates which were for the event and
earring it's actually really cute I like
it I think this yeah I think you need a
little oh great
about the head over to the red carpet I
couldn't find anything that wasn't camo
to cover myself today so I've got this
amazing scarf over top of my beautiful
Banana Republic gown but uh outfit looks
so many I'm so excited
they took down the tent so the red
carpet right now there's honestly
drenched other what's gonna happen foot
I'm gonna take you guys with me so here
we go I just noticed things the Fergie
song or she's like gee oh oh you
I wish I had I met everyone to see my
butter now I better put this time bye
guys look how pretty everything looks
amazing lots of people in the waiting
I'm just going
hélène looks so pretty oh my god I love
her dress
sorry - the carpet is about to open so
everyone's gonna start walking down and
we are about to go live so
my gosh
look at this guy's
I bring the clothes here to the red
carpet oh my gosh oh so much fun
I'm talking a lot of you my favorite
moments was taking my Legos on the
carpet and those that oh do you work for
Warner Brothers nope just a fan
they deserve their recognition so we
closed this heart down it is now dark
they're closing everything it's crazy